[Música]
se cumplen tres años desde que el Reino
Unido se retiró de manera oficial de la
Unión Europea el retiro prometía el
impulso de la economía de ese país
autonomía y en cierta forma también
prosperidad muchos soñaron con el
regreso del Reino Unido a hacer una
potencia mercantil que cubriera
diferentes mercados a nivel global pero
un error de cálculo ha entorpecido esas
promesas como por ejemplo la pandemia
del covid 19 la crisis energética
derivada de la invasión de Rusia a
Ucrania y también un esperado acuerdo de
libre comercio con Estados Unidos que
nunca tuvo lugar Estos y otros aspectos
han dificultado calcular de manera
exacta Cuál ha sido el impacto que ha
tenido el brexit que ha dejado en la
economía del Reino Unido hasta ahora
considerada la segunda economía más
importante del continente europeo está
aquí con nosotros en el estudio Jorge
Hurtado de la redacción de economía que
nos va a dar algunas cifras para poder
entender hasta cierto punto Jorge el
impacto que ha tenido el brexit en el
Reino Unido comenzó entonces
preguntándole a Jorge si la economía es
tal vez lo que más ha padecido
dentro del brexit porque vemos otros
otros asuntos como el comercio la
circulación de personas Pero qué dicen
los británicos en torno al ítem
económico bueno Santiago gracias por la
invitación primero la queja de muchos es
que aún no se ven esos beneficios del
brexit que se prometieron para esa
economía en 2020 el entonces Primer
Ministro Boris Johnson prometió que se
iba a desarrollar todo su potencial
económico pero hasta hoy sucede
Precisamente lo contrario ya que varios
indicadores muestran un rendimiento
inferior al de otras economías avanzadas
la situación actual se resume en una
crisis por la inflación anual más alta
en 40 años específicamente el 10,5%
anual reportado en diciembre de 2022
faltan también trabajadores en muchos
sectores como salud y atención social
que secunda en numerosos sectores en
huelga los trabajadores ferroviarios los
enfermeros empleados del servicio de
ambulancia maestros entre otros otros
centros de pensamiento y organismos
independientes revelan que es economía
habría crecido un 5,5% menos en 2022
precisamente por la salida de la Unión
Europea el 77% de las empresas admiten
que el brexit no les ayudó a expandir su
negocio y el 44% de empresas reportan ya
dificultades para visados del personal
paso ahora preguntarle Jorge por otros
ítems Como por ejemplo el comercio el
empleo la inversión como ha sido el
impacto que ha tenido el brexit en estas
áreas bueno otro sector bastante
afectado fue laboral ya que la salida de
la Unión Europea también supuso cambios
en las normas sobre la libre circulación
de los trabajadores un estudio muestra
que hay
330.000 trabajadores menos en el Reino
Unido como consecuencia del brexit
aunque solamente eso es el 1% de la mano
de obra total afecta ya a sectores como
el corte la hostelería y también el
comercio minorista con la salida del
Reino Unido del mercado único y la unión
aduanera en 2021 las empresas que
comercian con la Unión Europea se
enfrentan a nuevas normas nuevos
trámites y también nuevos controles de
algunas mercancías al principio se
produjo ciertos descenso de las
exportaciones británicas a la Unión
Europea pero una vez que se resolvieron
estos problemas iniciales los volúmenes
comerciales recuperaron los niveles que
tenían prepandemia según las cifras
oficiales pero el comercio pudo crecer
más de no haber sido por esa salida del
brexit según algunos analistas
recientemente también la cámara de
comercio británica encuestó a 500
empresas más de la mitad dijeron que
todavía estaban lidiando con este nuevo
sistema Ahora sí se analiza el comercio
de Reino Unido con el resto del mundo
así como en el comercio con la Unión
Europea en general ha disminuido en
relación con el tamaño de la economía
británica el comercio no se recuperó
tras la pandemia tan rápido como en
otras grandes economías y tras el brexit
también se firmaron 71 acuerdos
comerciales Eso sí la mayoría no son más
que repeticiones de los acuerdos que
Reino Unido tenía cuando formaba parte
del bloque otros analistas afirman que
la inversión se ha estancado desde el
referéndum ya que las empresas siguen
desconfiando del rumbo de la economía
además que también hay que sumarle el
tema político que también lo vamos a
analizar eso en cuanto a la economía
Muchas gracias Jorge por darnos esta
perspectiva general de lo que ha
significado el brexit para el Reino
Unido Gracias por habernos acompañado
aquí en el debate yo paso a recordarles
algunos datos adicionales sobre lo que
ha sido el brexit el 23 de junio del
2016 tuvo lugar ese referendo histórico
en el que el 17,4 millones de los
británicos votaron a favor de abandonar
la Unión Europea es decir un
51,9% de la población de ese país
europeo un 16,1 o 16,1 millones de
personas votaron por permanecer en el
bloque comunitario eso significa que el
48.1% de los habitantes querían seguir
siendo ciudadanos de la Unión Europea
tres años de intensas negociaciones
sellaron la salida oficial del país que
tuvo lugar entonces el 31 de enero del
año 2020 poniendo fin a 47 años de
relación muy estrecha entre Londres y
Bruselas en el marco de la Unión Europea
porque el Reino Unido y Bélgica ya
tenían relaciones históricas la pregunta
obvia pues toca hacer la cual es el
balance que deja el brexit tres años
después ha sido conveniente para el
Reino Unido Qué ventajas trajo para este
país Cómo impactó el brexit en la Unión
Europea es decir del otro lado del Canal
de la Mancha y por último aspectos como
la pandemia la guerra en Ucrania que lo
estábamos mencionando ahora y también la
falta de acuerdos comerciales fueron
razones de peso para dificultar para que
se dificulte esas promesas que traía el
brexit y que entusiasmó una buena parte
de la población del Reino Unido por eso
hoy en el debate de France 24 tres años
después que deja el brexit para
conversar sobre este tema hemos invitado
a Consuelo Tears Huerta ella es docente
e investigadora del instituto de
estudios internacionales de Barcelona el
eBay escuela de la que soy
orgullosamente egresado y doctor en
relaciones internacionales también de la
Universidad de edimburgo también está
con nosotros Damaso Morales Ramírez
coordinador del centro de estudios
europeos de la facultad de ciencias
políticas de la Universidad Autónoma de
México ustedes nuestros televidentes
también les recuerdo que son parte de
esta discusión de este debate pueden
dejar todos los comentarios las
preguntas que deseen a través de las
redes sociales estamos en Twitter en
Facebook y en instagram nos encuentran
como arroba France 24 guión bajo e s
@santilogo que es mi cuenta personal y
la etiqueta es numeral el debate f-24
todo Unido todo pegado y no olviden
también que todos los contenidos de
nuestro programa también están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Consuelo Consuelo Gracias por estar
con nosotros en el programa Gracias por
estar acá para hacer este análisis de lo
que deja el brexit y la pregunta Punto
de partida para para este debate con
suelo ha convenido o no el brexit al
Reino Unido veamos lo primero desde la
perspectiva del Reino Unido y luego
miramos desde la perspectiva de la Unión
Europea
Muchas gracias por la invitación
de la perspectiva de Reino Unido yo creo
que
como lo decía Jorge en la introducción
la verdad es que las grandes promesas
que se hicieron muchas de esas no no se
han logrado cumplir
una de las promesas importantes que
hacía el brexit era la idea de ganar
nuevamente control control de la
frontera pero también control por
ejemplo de con quién o qué tipo de
pactos comerciales se iban a atender
Ahora fue brexit y también como lo
comentaba Jorge es difícil poder
diferenciar entre las dificultades que
tenemos por brexit y las dificultades
que se dan por pandemia y las que se dan
por la guerra pero lo que hemos visto
ahora es básicamente un país que en este
minuto está con una crisis económica
importante con una inflación que está
llegando los dos dígitos con escasez de
trabajadores y Porque muchos los
trabajadores sobre todo de sectores Como
por ejemplo
hotelería o de mano de obra
son personas que venían de la Unión
Europea y que ahora ya no están ya no
están ahí como fuerza de trabajo también
existen ahora un montón de problemas en
el servicio de salud con bastantes
huelgas etcétera
entonces la La promesa de que iba a
venir con con muchos beneficios para el
Reino Unido hasta ahora al menos no no
se ha visto Sí y pasó a preguntarle a
Dámaso también comienzo dándole la
bienvenida Bienvenido al programa de
Amazon un gusto tenerlo con nosotros y
la misma pregunta ha convenido o no el
brexit cuál es su análisis
este gusto en saludarte Santiago
Consuelo un placer a todas luces el
brexit no ha convenido hemos visto por
los datos que ya nos presentaban y que
también mencionaba que efectivamente el
Reino Unido ha perdido en términos
económicos si bien hay que aclarar que
Reino Unido antes del brexit ya tenía
ciertos problemas económicos sobre todo
de inversión en infraestructura lo que
hizo el brexit sumado a lo que es la
crisis en Ucrania y algunos otros
elementos es hacer evidente ya una
historia de economía que no marchaba muy
bien en el Reino Unido entonces Más allá
de esta combinación de elementos este
pues las cifras que nos que nos
presentan o que están en los medios de
124 mil millones de dólares que pierde
el Reino Unido es una cifra realmente
considerable aquella propaganda que
decía 350 millones nosotros enviamos por
semana al reino digo a la Unión Europea
Bueno si lo hacemos como una suma
llegaría a los diecisiete mil millones
digamos de de de libras esterlinas
frente a las cien mil que están
perdiendo al año pues francamente fue un
pésimo negocio Además de que hay que
decirlo decían que ese dinero iba a ir
al sistema de salud y ahora el sistema
de salud de salud del Reino Unido está
en una verdadera crisis entonces lo que
tenemos ahí es que el discurso político
realmente se cayó la crisis económica Es
evidente en en las familias británicas
sobre todo las de menores ingresos que
francamente Pues están batallando para
cumplir y poder acceder a los a sus
cosas cotidianas damas o Consuelo
continuó con con damas o para hacer la
ronda a la inversa y aquí hay un punto
importante entendiendo el panorama en el
que se encontraba el Reino Unido antes
del brexit que ustedes lo van han
expuesto acá ya había una complicación
económica ya había cierta inestabilidad
Había una polarización que es un tema
que tenemos que abordar un poco más
adelante Pero la pregunta que les quiero
hacer es es el brexit una consecuencia
de la crisis política y económica que
venía presentando el Reino Unido de este
bipartidismo que tiene ya tantas
dificultades o el brexit generó esta
crisis política que está presentando el
Reino Unido cuál de las dos vías es
comienzo con Dámaso
Bueno en realidad serían ambas vías no
no pudiéramos determinarlo así tanta
gentemente no este estos discursos y y
visiones dicotómicas que tenían ambos
partidos con respecto precisamente al
brexit no Cameron buscó una salida
política y lo sabemos y esta salida
política fue el brexit hubo muy malos
cálculos políticos y una vez que ya
estaba en curso y la población votó a
favor de salirse por este cincuenta y
dos infracción por ciento pues
francamente lo que nos dice es
precisamente estos discursos después ya
muy polarizados y hasta cierto momento
manipulados la verdad sea dicha sobre
esta situación ahora bien el brexit o
más bien dicho la pertenencia a la Unión
Europea Siempre fue una espina por
decirlo así en el Reino Unido y lo
sabemos por todas esta historia de que
entro entro el general del gol en
aquellos momentos dijo No no ahora ya no
van a entrar y cuando una vez que
entraron pues querían esta Unión Europea
la carta decir aquí sí pertenezco aquí
no pertenezco aquí se participó aquí no
participo Entonces es una historia
bastante digamos empedrada la de la
relación de Reino Unido con con la Unión
Europea y que evidentemente ya formaba
parte de este discurso y de este de esta
forma de ser y de pensar la historia
propia del propio Reino Unido y Consuelo
Cuál es su perspectiva el brexit nos
llevó a esta crisis política en el Reino
Unido o la justamente una crisis
política nos llevó al brexit y a este
escenario en el que estamos ahora cuál
es su opinión Yo diría que es difícil
diferenciar la verdad me parece que las
dos cosas han jugado un papel por por
los dos lados Yo diría que lo que está
pasando ahora también es por brexit pero
también tiene que ver con un desgaste
del partido conservador en este minuto
ya lleva bastante bastantes años en el
poder y yo creo que le ha costado
poder
avanzar en las cosas que había que
habían prometido y poder también entre
ellos solucionar los problemas que está
atendiendo internos en el partido
conservador Entonces yo creo que eso
también ha sido un problema pero no
podría decir que una cosa es producto de
la otra o algo tan lineal la verdad creo
que hay un montón de factores que se
están jugando no podemos dejar de lado
la pandemia que ha pegado a todos los
gobiernos al gobierno del mundo yo creo
que eso también ha jugado un rol
fundamental esto también Consuelo nos
está indicando que tal vez está este
bipartidismo británico está en crisis
sus bases están erosionadas Y es momento
que a nivel político el Reino Unido
contempla la posibilidad de abrir un
poco más el espectro cómo lo puede
analizar
Sí ahora la verdad que en estos sistemas
que son de de bipartidismo es difícil
que entre un tercer partido digamos a
que pueda jugar algún rol
importante Entonces no no me parece
difícil eso sí Yo creo que tal vez tiene
que repensar ciertas cosas para poder
nuevamente reencantar a un electorado
que está bastante desilusionado de los
dos lados digamos yo creo que eso sí se
puede hacer si algo caracterizó este
proceso de la salida del Reino Unido de
la Unión Europea ha sido la polarización
desde antes del referendo ya se veía una
sociedad completamente dividida
justamente por este desgaste político
pero también con cierto cansancio por
algunas políticas de Bruselas pero
también porque en algunos escenarios el
Reino Unido se sentía un poco superior
con respecto a la Unión Europea por todo
este pasado mercantil y de potencia a
nivel internacional
ahí entonces Cabe hacer la pregunta si
estamos ante uno de los grandes ejemplos
de la historia de las grandes campañas
de desinformación Porque si hubo una
campaña que se la jugó a lo largo de
estos meses y a lo largo de de de hizo
uso de los medios de comunicación fue el
brexit mostrando las dos caras de lo que
podía ser un escenario o el otro Este es
un ejemplo de amazo de una exitosa
campaña de desinformación de la cual
fueron víctimas los británicos
Sin lugar a dudas este ambas partes
utilizaron todos sus argumentos y
estrategias políticas y de comunicación
y Pero pero esta idea de del típico
autobús o con esta leyenda de que
estamos enviando trescientos cincuenta
millones a la semana al Unión Europea y
queremos invertirlos en el sistema de
salud No Recuerda que ella frases de
margaritacher donde decía queremos que
nos devuelva nuestro dinero entonces hay
hay reminiscencias hay discursos que
venden muy bien y que evidentemente hay
que decirlo Insisto que este Reino Unido
ya tenía problemas económicos pero por
el por el mal manejo de la clase
política para la clase política no
solamente de Reino Unido sino de otras
capitales europeas es más fácil culpar a
Bruselas de los males que están
sucediendo al interior que reconocer su
propia culpa o parte de su propia culpa
en este sentido sin lugar a dudas el uso
de los medios
desinformación que se dio pues jugó una
buena parte y ahora tenemos que casi un
57% mucho más o más del 52 que votó para
salirse ahora estaría reconsiderando que
si hubiera la posibilidad regresarían a
la Unión Europea por qué porque
evidentemente no tenían la información
Clara y concisa sino más bien una
información manipulada para favorecer
una posición política tengo el dato acá
de acuerdo a una encuesta realizada por
el diario británico de independent la
encuesta indica que el 65% de los
británicos
le gustaría que la consulta es decir ese
referendo inicial en donde ellos
decidieron si apostaban por el retiro o
la permanencia fuera repetido otra vez
en los cuatro países que componen al
Reino Unido también el 56% de los
votantes admite que fue un error irse de
La Unión europea un 56% tampoco es una
cifra muy alta y no es que haya consenso
entre los británicos entonces en en
cuanto a la opinión sobre sobre el
brexit esto evidencia Consuelo una
sociedad que continúa estando
completamente polarizada y dividida en
torno a este tema es decir la grieta no
se ha cerrado entre los británicos
no no no está cerrado Ahora yo creo que
también es importante porque esa
encuesta que que tú mencionas es cierto
es cierto que se ha ido aumentado la
idea dentro de de la población que el
brexit fue un error pero también hay un
estudio que se hizo hace poco que fueron
algunos investigadores de la uropía
University institute que básicamente
plantean que esto también tiene que ver
con El reemplazo de votantes es decir
viene llegando un grupo de votantes de
que ya recién cumplieron los 18 y otros
votantes que ya han muerto luego del de
la votación entonces que esa diferencia
digamos ese cambio pueda también también
tener que ver con el cambio de votantes
más que la gente esté efectivamente
cambiando su opinión al respecto digamos
entonces
Sí ahora Hay ciertos acuerdos también en
la población por ejemplo la encuesta
ipsos que salió ahora dice que el 84% de
la población de Reino Unido considera
que hay que tener una estrecha relación
con la Unión Europea por ejemplo Y eso
también ha aumentado desde la última
encuesta que se hizo en junio entonces
también Creo que están llegando a
ciertos acuerdos
Hay ciertos acuerdos consuelos Dámaso
continuó con usted en en México
preguntándole Existe algún escenario es
posible Un regreso del Reino Unido a la
Unión Europea eso es un proceso que
pueda revertirse porque también lo
veíamos como algo imposible que un país
se retirara de la Unión Europea ya
sucedió ahora otro escenario que vemos
poco factible es que regrese esto puede
darse
es muy difícil que esto pueda darse
porque incluso
aquellos laboristas que estuvieron a
favor de continuar su relación con la
Unión Europea Pues bueno algunos pues
tienen que adecuarse a la realidad y más
bien Buscar otras salidas que puede ser
una visión que es llamada minimalista
Qué quiere decir que poco a poco
fuéramos generando otros acuerdos otras
puertas otras condiciones que permitan
al Reino Unido precisamente tener una
relación buena con la Unión Europea en
todas las materias sin lugar a dudas
pero particularmente la financiera la
comercial no este y que esto permitiera
al al Reino Unido ir saliendo de sus
problemas más que un regreso Pero para
esto pues se necesita pues una gran
digamos compromiso político y yo pienso
que ahí es uno pantalones de Aquiles que
no se ve que haya un compromiso político
de la de la clase política porque no
quieren ahorita poner en riesgo digamos
esta su su propia posición política y
como hay elecciones en menos de dos años
yo creo que de aquí a dos años no vamos
a ver Muchos avances hay que hablar con
suelo de un punto importante y es que ya
han logrado firmar 71 acuerdo
comerciales acuerdos comerciales con
diferentes países entre ellos Australia
Nueva Zelanda que son importantes para
el mercado británico pero como lo
explicaba Jorge en la introducción del
programa Son acuerdos que también ya
estaban pactados al interior de la Unión
Europea entonces básicamente lo que está
haciendo es ahora negociarlos
directamente Pero hay un acuerdo en
particular que no ha tenido lugar y que
era la gran esperanza de el gobierno
británico y es el acuerdo de libre
comercio con Estados Unidos esto sigue
sobre la mesa esto ya se dio por cerrado
y sentado que no sucederá o el Reino
Unido siga haciéndolo bien Washington
para llegar a ese acuerdo
o sea en algún momento me parece que fue
flash quien planteó que que en 48 horas
se podía atender un acuerdo con
con Estados Unidos y no no se ha logrado
no tengo Claridad de Cómo están Ahora
las negociaciones al respecto pero
sí De todas maneras Estados Unidos es un
Aliado de Reino Unido por lo tanto yo
imagino que siguen y continúan esas esas
negociaciones pero por ahora no hay
absolutamente nada que esté próximo o
que se sepa que que viene algún acuerdo
ya hablemos internamente dentro del
Reino Unido la cohesión de los
diferentes países que Lo componen vimos
la intención de Escocia de querer hacer
un referendo para independizarse un
escenario que ya hemos visto en años
anteriores pero es un escenario que
ahora es más complicado que llegue a
materializarse porque tiene que ser
Londres la instancia política que
proponga ese referéndum puede venir de
parte del gobierno de Escocia
directamente pero también Hay ciertos
problemas con Irlanda del Norte
justamente por esa frontera con la
República de Irlanda esto el brexit está
poniendo en peligro la cohesión del país
al mediano y largo plazo damas o cómo lo
ve usted Bueno en realidad como ya
habíamos comentado si hay una
polarización política pero también hay
una polarización nacional y una
polarización regional histórica
particularmente entre las con el tema de
Irlanda pero en efecto en el caso de
Escocia si bien no pueden llevar a cabo
este referéndum de separación está en el
ánimo está en el aire cuando murió la
Reina Isabel precisamente segunda salió
ese tema una vez más y cada vez que hay
un evento como esto Pues el tema está
ahí presente ya hay manifestaciones esto
lo único que nos está comentando es que
hay polarizaciones de término en
términos políticos pero también estas
polarizaciones regionales que continúan
la historia con Irlanda sabemos
que es muy muy complicada y y esta
incapacidad de llegar al día de hoy a un
acuerdo que digamos fuera positivo para
todas las partes respecto a cómo va a
operar o cómo se llevaría a cabo esta
frontera pues este y que no ha llegado a
una solución política y tiene paralizado
precisamente al gobierno de Irlanda del
Norte Pues nos habla de lo complicado
que es el brexit y que no es solamente
una cuestión obvia de lo económico de la
inversión sino también que aterriza en
el ánimo social y en los ánimos
nacionalistas y en cuestiones tan viejas
e históricas como puede ser precisamente
estos acuerdos no entre las dos irlandes
Consuelo su opinión sobre este tema la
cohesión del Reino Unido Y esa relación
con Irlanda del Norte
Sí bueno eso se Eso sí se viene se viene
complicado
hace hace poco que hubo elecciones en en
Escocia se vio como él sentí que es el
partido de del actual primera ministra
obtiene una gran cantidad de votos Y eso
de alguna manera estaba diciendo que la
gente que votaba por el agente que
finalmente querría salirse del Reino
Unido por lo tanto
se supone que existe el apoyo para esto
y básicamente la lógica que hay detrás y
que se está ocupando bastante Es que la
gente en Escocia no votó en su mayoría
por por salirse de la Unión Europea por
lo tanto esto cambiaría las reglas del
juego y haría entonces que Escocia
pudiera
pudiese tratar de independizarse ahora
eso eso por un lado ahora el tema de
Irlanda del Norte está particularmente
complicado porque es una frontera muy
sensible
porque Bueno ahora se van a cumplir los
veinticinco años del del good Friday del
acuerdo que finalmente calmó un poco el
conflicto en Irlanda del Norte
y se esperaría que para esa fecha Ya se
tuviera algún tipo de acuerdo entre la
Unión Europea y la y el Reino Unido
ahora creo que en ese sentido las
noticias por en esto específicamente
pueden ser no tan malas en el en el
sentido en que
la Unión Europea Me parece que está en
este momento un poco menos asustada del
efecto no dominó que pensó que iba a
tener en su momento el que Reino Unido
se fuera por lo tanto creo que tiende
ahora más más apertura para poder
transar un poco más con y cooperar un
poco más con Reino Unido de hecho hasta
hace poco se se llevó un acuerdo
finalmente para acceder a los sistemas
informáticos del Reino Unido por ejemplo
es un acuerdo de intercambio de datos
entre el Reino Unido y la Unión Europea
en el contexto de este protocolo
entonces han habido avances Yo espero
que que avance aún más digamos claro y
ahí puedo pensar que tal vez la guerra
en Ucrania le sirvió también a la Unión
Europea para mantener un poco más la
cohesión era necesario mantenerse Unidos
para hacer un frente común para poder
apoyar a Ucrania ante la invasión de
Rusia y eso le ha convenido de pronto a
sus países que estaban un poco dudosos
sobre el tema Pues ahora se ha visto así
sea lento pero la cohesión de la Unión
Europea se ha mantenido y
reforzada gracias a la guerra en Ucrania
quiero que veamos la otra cara de la
moneda porque vemos que el análisis pues
no es muy positivo que digamos en en
materia económica en materia social y
política para el Reino Unido pero para
cerrar el tema del Reino Unido y pasar
al otro lado del Canal de la Mancha y
ver la Unión Europea qué le deja de
positivo al Reino Unido entonces haberse
retirado si hay algo positivo para
destacar Consuelo hago la ronda la
inversa
algo positivo para destacar yo creo que
una de las cosas que que tal vez el
Reino Unido quería y que y que fue una
de las razones por las que brexit ganó
tiene que ver con el tema migratorio
y Reino Unido finalmente Ha logrado
tener este sistema de puntos y que ha
hecho que entre una cantidad de
migrantes que son los migrantes que
ellos quieren que ingresen y que son de
repente altamente calificados y que eso
sí están teniendo obteniendo visas
entonces puede ser que eso sea algo algo
positivo para desde la perspectiva de
Reino Unido digamos
y parada pasó su perspectiva Qué hay de
positivo de todo esto
Bueno uno de los argumentos también que
presentó el Reino Unido fue esta
capacidad de soberanía sobre sus leyes
no sobre su sistema judicial y que veía
minimizado por la corte de justicia de
la Unión Europea y esto pues para
digamos gran un amplio público del Reino
Unido es positivo efectivamente hayan
podido recuperar esta soberanía digamos
judicial jurídica de instituciones que
debemos decirlo pues tienen una larga
historia no este en avances jurídicos
importantes
pasamos ahora al otro lado del Canal de
la Mancha pasemos a Bruselas esto que ha
representado para la Unión Europea para
este bloque estos tres años de brexit y
este tire afloje con Londres por llegar
algunos acuerdos ya hay un marco más o
menos bien establecido pero costó costó
muchísimo establecer una relación fluida
entre las partes con suelo su balance
Yo creo que un poco como comentaba
anteriormente la Unión Europea está
bastante hostil Por decirlo de alguna
manera en un principio básicamente
porque temía que si se iba a Reino Unido
entonces otros países también se iban a
empezar a ir y yo creo que ahora Existe
mayor tranquilidad básicamente porque la
gente andaba Unión Europea está viendo
que las cosas no le están funcionando a
Reino Unido Entonces eso está hasta
calmando un poco las aguas
yo creo que también la Unión Europea
está bastante reticente a la idea que
finalmente Reino Unido solamente
escogiera las cosas que ellos querían
que era por ejemplo libre comercio pero
no libre circulación de personas
pero me parece que ahora por lo que tú
decías también por el tema de la guerra
porque se ha visto que es necesario
Igualmente mantener cooperación porque
finalmente igual Reino Unido sigue
siendo vecino de Europa del continente
digamos entonces la cooperación va a
tener que seguir y yo creo que la Unión
Europea ahora está más dispuesta que
antes
en cooperación con con Reino Unido el
tema no está tan tan caliente en este
momento creo Dámaso su perspectiva
sí sin lugar a duda las circunstancias
de coyuntura que la guerra en Ucrania
este modificó de manera importante el
terreno de las relaciones entre la Unión
Europea y el Reino Unido particularmente
por supuesto en materia de seguridad si
bien siempre se mantuvo esta cooperación
digamos de seguridad militar Pero esto
de poder dar nuestro datos o acceso a
nuestros datos son temas muy sensibles y
de hecho que se haya avanzado ahí
significa una buena voluntad el Reino
Unido tiene sus propias problemáticas y
lo que menos le conviene es tener un
flanco áspero precisamente con la Unión
Europea y la Unión Europea pues para
dudas la guerra en Ucrania lo que menos
le conviene es tener también esta
relación áspera con el Reino Unido ambas
partes han comprendido que la
cooperaciones del mejor camino y
seguramente
podríamos ver avances todavía está la
cuestión de pesca la cuestión de las
irlandes en fin algunos temas ahí un
poco sensibles pero que sin lugar a
dudas ahora se pudiera avanzar de manera
más clara también quedan par de minutos
para finalizar el programa llegamos al
bloque de las conclusiones comienzo con
Consuelo Qué puede venir para esta
relación ya llevamos tres años desde el
retiro del Reino Unido pero qué más
puede venir para para estas dos partes
en el mismo continente que sigue para
esa relación entre Londres y Bruselas
para la conclusión del programa Mira yo
creo que ahora ya viene el momento de
pensar en cómo van a se va a operar a
futuro Cómo se va a profundizar por
ejemplo en los acuerdos de cooperación
comercial Cómo se van a recuperar las
confianzas yo creo que eso es
fundamental para empezar a avanzar en
acuerdos de repente tal vez más simple
como simplificar los controles de las
fronteras por ejemplo Cómo mejorar el
sistema de Visas etcétera entonces yo
creo que eso
lo que debiese empezar ahora a ocurrir
entre entre Reino Unido y la Unión
Europea Cómo aprendemos a cooperar de
nuevo Cómo aprendemos a recuperar la
confianza y yo a eso me atrevo añadirle
Consuelo también un poco que el Reino
Unido se estabilice ha tenido muchos
acontecimientos en los últimos años el
brexit la el fallecimiento de la reina
los cambios de gobiernos la inflación
ese inicio de de la lucha contra la
pandemia que fue tan criticado por por
diferentes sectores por la forma como el
entonces Primer Ministro Boris Johnson
manejó la pandemia eso también le ha
costado estabilidad al Reino Unido yo lo
añadiría paso a preguntarle a damas o su
conclusión para el cierre del programa
sí sin lugar a dudas Debe de haber
avances importantes en una cuestión
fundamental que son todas las funciones
técnicas que tienen que ver con el
comercio bilateral no y de ahí pasar a
las cuestiones un poco más viendo el de
política y de mejor entendimiento y en
este sentido yo sí creo que pueden haber
caminos
que pudiera beneficiar a ambas partes lo
que decía hace un rato de ir paso a paso
poco a poquito abriendo estas nuevas
ventanas de intercambio en muchos
sentidos también un buen materia
migratoria este y que al final de
cuentas va a beneficiar tanto a la Unión
Europea como a Reino Unido porque a
ninguna de las dos partes le conviene
tener una mala relación ambos saldrían
muy fortalecidas precisamente
Si llegan a estos mayores acuerdos sin
que se regrese a ser parte de la Unión
Europea Además está la buena experiencia
que hay con otros países europeos que no
son Unión Europea pero tienen una muy
buena relación con Bruselas y tienen
excelentes acuerdos comerciales y de
circulación cito por ejemplo el caso de
Noruega o el caso de Islandia o el caso
de Suiza que no pertenecen al bloque
comunitario pero tienen una relación
bastante cercana en términos comerciales
también en cierta forma políticos y en
otras áreas Consuelo damas o un gusto
estar con ustedes en el programa gracias
por haber hecho este análisis para la
audiencia de France 24 en toda América
Latina Muchísimas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros En nombre del equipo
técnico también a ustedes Les
agradecemos la sintonía la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Laura
garzón y la producción de invitados
estuvo a cargo de Tania Herrera
muchísimas gracias y Pueden seguir
dejando todos sus comentarios y
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
sigan con nosotros
[Música]